[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au programme de l'actualité des
infos pratiques et des idées de sortie
voici le programme de ce 31 janvier
une deuxième journée de grève contre la
réforme des retraites à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats aujourd'hui à 500
000 personnes ont manifesté à Paris
selon la CGT et dans le cortège des
yvelinois parti en bus de différents
endroits du département dont trappes les
chiffres de la mobilisation dans le
département dans nos informations du
jour tout au long du mois de janvier
période traditionnelle des vœux TV 78
reçoit les maires de 50 ans en Yvelines
pour parler des grands projets de
l'année 2023 dans leur ville ce soir
suite et fin avec Élancourt travaux sur
la colline en vue des Jeux olympiques de
2024 commissariat du futur et
aménagement du quartier des petits prix
à quoi faut-il s'attendre le maire de la
commune Jean-Michel fourgousse et notre
invité et puis un anniversaire dans ce 7
8 celui de la troupe du crâne qui
célèbre ses 40 ans une compagnie
théâtrale emblématique qui dévil de
Maurepas et de Coignières composés
d'amateurs à l'origine elle sait depuis
professionnaliser on revient sur
l'histoire et on parle des prochains
temps forts à venir pour l'association
avec son président Christophe fleuret
et on parlera aussi d'autres
anniversaires d'un autre anniversaire
dans ce 7 8 celui de Londres qui est
fait ses 20 ans à Vélizy c'est une salle
de spectacle installée dans la commune
de Vélizy-Villacoublay d'autres invités
également qui sont installés avec moi en
plateau il y a Audrey Rouen bonsoir
alors vous êtes l'organisatrice du
tremplin des voiles la finale de la 8e
saison de ce concours de chant qui est
proposé par l'association la voix en
scène se tient le 11 février à
Magny-les-Hameaux est-ce que vous pouvez
rappeler quel est le principe du
tremplin des bois le principe du
tremplin des voies c'est découvrir des
talents soit des jeunes talents soit qui
ont un certain niveau et au fur et à
mesure on les amène jusqu'en final donc
il y a plusieurs étapes plusieurs étapes
qu'on va en revenir sur ces étapes tout
à l'heure il y aura aussi deux
candidates qui seront parmi les 22
finalistes de cette 8e saison du
tremplin des boissons avec nous tout à
l'heure en plateau de ligaments Xavier
Brissard bonsoir alors vous êtes vous
éducateur de rugby on va parler avec
vous justement de rugby de formation
avec une actualité des six nations
notamment qui va débuter la Coupe du
Monde aussi de rugby qui approche en
cette année 2023 et c'est aussi
l'occasion de parler de ce livre que
vous avez publié il y a quelques mois
aux éditions des trois colonnes c'est
l'art de la guerre du rugby alors l'art
de la guerre bah ça fait tout de suite
penser au livre du maître Sunzu est-ce
que c'est inspiré c'est une déclinaison
c'est c'est en référence ça ne s'ouvre
effectivement et à ses principes
philosophiques le livre n'a rien du tout
d'un traité guerrier c'est plus une
philosophie de vie comme les le rugby on
va parler tout à l'heure un peu plus
précisément de de cet ouvrage il y aura
un passionné de rugby aussi avec nous en
plateau qui est aussi journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 à suivre dans cette
émission 7 8 un reportage hommage à Marc
Pfeiffer l'ancien indirecteur du théâtre
de Poissy a disparu prématurément à
l'âge de 64 ans on fera également le
point sur les informations du jour avec
vous Céline Charles bonsoir bonsoir et
on parlera notamment de ce mouvement de
grève un deuxième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites comme chaque mardi les
insolites de Turbide qui va faire le
point aussi sur ses informations qui
sortent de l'ordinaire que vous avez
peut-être raté dans le département des
Yvelines et puis l'astuce de votre chef
yvelinois pour briller chez vous en
cuisine mais avant tout cela petit coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
un ciel qui devrait être nuageux demain
matin dans les Yvelines au niveau des
températures il fera 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Versailles à
Rambouillet compter 5 degrés et dans
l'après-midi météo France prévoit
quelques éclairs si côté température
prévoyaient de 8 à 9 degrés en moyenne
et demain nous fêterons les et là
[Musique]
les informations du jour avec vous
célinecha et on commence par cette
deuxième journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites de bus sont partis
en fin de matinée de Trappes une
centaine de personnes étaient présentes
ce matin pour le secrétaire général de
la CGT cheminots de Trappes la
mobilisation ne s'essouffle pas écoutée
oui a priori en terme de manifestation
en tout cas même les renseignements
généraux enfin la police en gros estime
qu'il y aura sans doute un peu plus de
monde que la dernière fois en termes de
grévise c'est comparable ou certains
secteurs peut-être une légère baisse
mais façon les chiffres déjà tellement
élevé que c'était pas possible de faire
plus mais en terme de manifestations oui
ça va être sans doute un peu plus mais
ce qui va déterminant pour la suite ça
va être aussi est-ce qu'il y a des
secteurs qui entrent en grève aux
conductible qui bloquent l'économie
c'est ça qu'on essaie de construire et
ça va se décanter un peu dans les
semaines à venir
alors parliez parmi les manifestants des
habitudes mais aussi des salariés pour
qui manifester étaient une première
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
descends dans la rue parce que cette
réforme elle est injuste et violente je
suis pas contre la réforme mais là on
touche à un point sensible c'est la vie
des gens et quand on est carrière longue
comme moi et qui ont devait s'arrêter à
60 parce que j'ai 43 ans de cotisation
et qu'aujourd'hui on me demande 44 ans
je dis non parce qu'on touche à un
morceau de ma vie alors d'autres qu'on
voit dans les Yvelines étaient
organisées pour se rendre à la
manifestation place de la République à
Paris des bus sont partis ce matin de
Guyancourt Mantes-la-Jolie ou encore
Rambouillet la CGT 78 nous a informé que
21 cars étaient partis contre 15 le 19
janvier autre mouvement qui concerne
cette fois-ci le mécontentement des
parents de la ville de Plaisir hier soir
ils ont occupé l'école élémentaire
Marcel Gentet de 16h30 à 19h45 pour
discuter de la situation des écoles en
cause la nouvelle carte scolaire qui
sera mise en place progressivement dès
la rentrée 2023 elle implique entre
autres la suppression des directeurs
d'école maternelle et de certains postes
d'ATSEM ainsi que la fermeture
définitive de plusieurs écoles
maternelles alors 3 ans après les
premiers cas de covid-19 en France il y
a eu on se rappelle on s'en rappelle
bien sûr de ce confinement le
gouvernement va mettre officiellement
fin à plusieurs mesures anti covid dès
demain alors concrètement qu'est-ce qui
va changer premièrement si vous êtes
testé positif vous n'êtes plus obligé de
vous isoler vous serez seulement invité
à respecter les gestes barrières et à
éviter les contacts avec les personnes
fragiles de même et cela semble logique
les arrêts de travail dérogatoire 100
jours de carence pour les personnes
testées positives ne seront plus
possibles autre changement la
réalisation d'un test au bout de deux
jours pour les cas contacts ne sera plus
requises non plus enfin le suivi des cas
contacts et des personnes testées
positives par l'assurance maladie va
cesser définitivement pour ces
changements au premier février vous nous
parlez à présent Céline d'un partenariat
entre mobile eyes qui est la marque du
groupe Renault dédié aux nouvelles
mobilités et l'agglomération de 50 ans
en Yvelines oui alors l'idée de pouvoir
récolter des datas des données via des
capteurs intégrés dans des véhicules de
la marque Renault ces capteurs
permettront par exemple d'évaluer l'état
de la voirie les besoins en bornes de
recharge de véhicule électrique la
pollution de l'air ou encore le flux de
circulation le but est ensuite de faire
remonter ces données au territoire de 50
ans en Yvelines pour que l'agglomération
puisse développer des infrastructures
des infrastructures qui répondent aux
besoins des usagers en clair renforcer
l'efficacité des politiques publiques du
territoire enfin un job dating sera
organisé par la Mission locale et
l'agence de garde d'enfants Babychou
service ce sera ce jeudi 2 février à 14h
sur le site de la Mission Locale de
plaisir de nombreux postes en alternance
sont à pourvoir pour le cap
accompagnement éducatif petit enfance et
le bac pro accompagnement soins et
services à la personne alors pas de
diplôme requis les débutants sont
acceptés il faut seulement avoir 16 ans
maximum minimum plus d'informations
numéro et site internet qui s'affiche
ci-dessous merci Céline et si vous aussi
près de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'une
information d'un feu qui je vous fais
réagir n'hésitez pas à le dire sur les
réseaux sociaux à le partageant avec le
hashtag 78
[Musique]
tout au long du mois de janvier TV 78 a
reçu les différents maires des communes
de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines pour parler
de l'année 2023 qui s'ouvre dans leur
commune suite et fin ce soir en ce 31
janvier avec le maire d'Élancourt et
président de l'agglomération à
Jean-Michel faugus l'entretien était
enregistré il y a quelques jours
[Musique]
et avec moi Jean-Michel fourgaud bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez présenté vos vœux
jeudi dernier en tant que président de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines on
va en parler dans un instant mais c'est
le maire d'Élancourt qu'on reçoit avant
tout ce soir comme tout les mers des
villes de l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines alors si une nouvelle année qui
s'ouvre cette année 2023 mais d'abord
peut-être un retour sur l'année 2022 qui
a été aussi celle où les collectivités
locales ont commencé à faire face à la
hausse du coup de l'énergie est-ce que
cette augmentation brutale qui a pour
conséquence aussi plus tard peut-être
des baisses de dotation est-ce que ça ça
va permettre quand même la continuité de
vos projets d'investissement aussi à
Élancourt ou est-ce que ça les stocke
oui dans la mesure où le gouvernement
arrive à négocier bien sûr de stabiliser
le prix l'énergie ce qui est fondamental
deuxièmement s'il arrive à remettre le
nucléaire qui n'aurait jamais dû être
perturbé par nos écologistes enfin je
vous rappelle que la
contre le nucléaire ça va vous coûter 50
milliards donc vous imaginez si ça ne
redescend dessus bon donc on est prudent
parce que les chiffres aujourd'hui vous
avez vu le niveau du déficit budgétaire
1960 milliards le niveau de dette le
niveau un nouvel empreinte de 110 enfin
on sent bien que l'État ne contrôle plus
ni son budget ni les frontières
ni je dirais
la santé regardez un peu les systèmes la
sécurité
l'état il y a aucune réforme donc on
sent bien qu'on est dans une période de
non maîtrise et dans ces cas-là bien sûr
et puis en plus dans une période de
guerre entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
demain si ça s'étend du mec aujourd'hui
la mondialisation c'est ça c'est qu'il y
a deux pays qui font qui se battent
s'impact bien sûr tous l'économie
mondiale et en termes de sobriété
énergétique est-ce qu'il y a eu des
conséquences justement sur sur votre
livre des décisions à prendre bien sûr
on a eu des factures de multiplication
par 5 à 10 forcément il y a eu des
décisions de réduire même encore il y a
réce et les vœux 50 ans ont été réduits
pas le moindre trace de saumon pas de
pas de choses comme le foie gras ou des
choses comme ça à réduction de tout et
je les bons les coups partout mais pour
anticiper parce que on était équilibré
bien sûr de toute façon une collectivité
c'est pas comme l'état nous on peut pas
se faire un déficit de 60 milliards oui
bon donc c'est équilibré en plus on
baisse on baisse la tête en général 50
ans bon voilà
en tout cas ce j'espère que ce prix de
l'énergie ça va pas durer plus d'un an
parce que là à ce moment-là ça va mettre
des sociétés en difficulté c'est déjà le
cas faut pas se lever donc
alors même alors le problème c'est que
l'État il compense il est pas possible
compensait mais compenser avec quoi il
est déficitaire si l'équilibré oui c'est
un sens mais si c'est je paye mais je
vous ramène ça en impôts parce que c'est
ça s'il est difficile ça veut dire qu'il
vous ramène ça en impôts vous voyez
c'est pas il y a pas de générosité là
donc voilà il faut en tout cas être
responsable dire la situation de la
France aujourd'hui il faut arrêter de
raconter n'importe quoi il y a une
augmentation de la dette qui est
fracassante en 2012 il y avait il y
avait 1800 milliards de de il y avait
1800 milliards de dettes et
en la fin du mandat de Monsieur Macron
vous aurez 3600 milliards vous aurez
doublé la dette entre 2012 et 2027 il va
falloir le payer tout ça c'est les
Français qui vont le payer une dette
c'est un taux d'intérêt en plus voilà
faut dire que la situation quand même
budgétaire et très grave et c'est
toujours délicat de d'accepter un chèque
de quelqu'un qui en fait
qui en fait n'a pas d'équilibre
budgétaire il y a comme une volonté
Élancourt on sait que c'est l'image des
Yvelines c'est une ville qui a un pied
dans la ville un pied dans la campagne
aussi de maintenir aussi ce bien-être
des habitants c'est l'une de vos
préoccupations alors par exemple sur
l'aspect environnement et l'espèce
sportif puisque c'est qu'on a un site
olympique dans lesquels sur 50 ans on en
a un Élancourt bon on va passer de 400
km de pistes cycla d'ailleurs vous
remarqué que nous
on parle moins d'écologie mais on en
fait plus que les écologistes faudra un
jour s'interroger sur les cellules qui
causent et qui font bon ça sert à rien
de briller sur les de raconter vous
beaucoup de choses voilà nous on les
fait on peut dire qu'on va être une des
capitales mondiale du vélo alors on n'a
pas le choix donc on passe de 400 km à
600 km bien sûr dans les années à venir
d'Élancourt qui sera l'un des sites
olympiques qui va accueillir le VTT il y
a aussi on le sait vous êtes venus
d'ailleurs avec votre petite tablette le
numérique c'est un de vos chevaux de
bataille l'éducation aussi est-ce qu'il
y aura de nouveaux projets cette année
de nouvelles choses où ça va continuer
oui alors l'éducation on a démarré et
c'est là où vous voyez l'aspect d'une
centralisation de l'État on a voilà il
faut nous faire confiance on a modifié
la l'éducation à partir des lancers
maintenant de 50 ans en Yvelines on a
modifié la pédagogie à tel point c'est
qu'on a même été invité à disposition
universelle du Dubaï pour représenter la
France et pour montrer l'innovation
pédagogique c'est un outil qui apprécié
aussi par les parents par les parents
par les enfants par les profs les profs
prennent plus de plaisir à renseigner et
les élèves prennent plus de plaisir à
apprendre mais bon mais chers amis vous
imaginez le succès il est et ça s'étend
toutes les villes de Saint-Quentin mais
toute la France est en train de bien sûr
de et on a eu deux missions
parlementaires bien sûr pour expliquer
ça donc ça à l'éducation c'est une
réussite on va continuer en fait on va
faire un continuum entre l'école
primaire
secondaire et jusqu'à l'université 50 en
une je vous rappelle qui enfin c'est
clair devient la première université
scientifique mondiale en mathématiques
intégration progressive de l'uvsk avec
je peux vous dire on est on est très
scientifique on a un modèle éducatif
très scientifique bien sûr à Élancourt à
Saint-Quentin et dans tout le dans tout
bien sûr tout Paris siècle alors dans
les grands projets il y a des projets
d'aménagement par exemple celui du
quartier des petits prix avec la
restructuration d'espaces publics
d'immeubles également c'est un projet de
80 millions d'euros qui va s'étendre sur
plusieurs années ce qu'on va avoir du
concret des cette année dès 2023 ah ben
je sais pas exactement le planning moi
par mois mais c'est une décision
budgétaire qui est actée c'est quand
même important parce que vous pouvez
prendre des tas de choses si vous n'avez
pas le budget on l'a ça y est les
partenaires qui suivent c'est un très
gros budget bien sûr de de rénovation
d'amélioration de la qualité de vie au
petit près on est très fiers on a
travaillé de longues années là-dessus et
eu des concertations quand même très
très importantes donc voilà c'est
quelque chose qui va être lancé dès
cette année dès cette année donc pour ce
quartier des petits points on en parlait
aussi c'est Jeux Olympiques qui vont
arriver à l'échéance olympique qui
arrive en 2024 et ses travaux sur la
colline d'Élancourt différents projets
on l'a vu pour la colline et donc un
futurolympique pour pour ce site ça ça
débute aussi des cette année ça a déjà
débuté ou est-ce qu'on en est sur sur le
dossier des travaux alors il y a une
grosse bagarre je crois qu'avec le
savoir qui voulait prendre
quand même sur la colline parce qu'ils
ont effectivement des montagnes histoire
mais on leur a expliqué quand même que
ça se passe ou ça au mois de juillet au
mois d'août je vois pas très bien en
quoi la neige va jouer un rôle important
bon bref mais cela dit bon on a regagné
grâce à la Pécresse genre qui a dit à
1000 points sur la table a dit non c'est
les JO de Paris c'est au dérange pas les
gars bon a priori 50 ans de Yvelines
c'est à moins de 30 km de Paris par
l'autoroute 100 feux rouge quasiment
puisqu'on arrive sur un encours sans feu
rouge de Paris bon en moins de 30
minutes hors encombrement bon voilà on
touche pas à ça en plus on voit Paris de
la colline d'Élancourt
point culminant derrière la Tour Eiffel
voilà donc c'est parti les travaux ont
commencé d'ailleurs
non non on est très content ça fait 30
ans qu'on se dispute tous entre élus
quelquefois pour le projet il y a une
grande débat machin là moi a priori tout
le monde est unanime sur le fait que les
JO plus gros événements mondial tout le
monde s'est rangé derrière ce projet et
franchement on est très content avec un
site qui sera ouvert bien sûr aux
habitants à la suite on parle de
cyclisme justement le tracé du Tour de
France va partir du vélodrome de 50 ans
en Yvelines pour la dernière étape sur
cette année 2023 il va passer aussi à
Élancourt ce tracé du Tour de France
pour la dernière étape alors on apprend
ça on a pris ça bien sympa le
département c'est grâce au département
merci d'ailleurs sur le fait d'avoir la
dernière le dernier départ la dernière
étape du Tour de France qui part du vélo
du vélo Drôme donc les chaussures
spectaculaire ou sans plus mais est un
totem quasiment devient un totem en
terme de sport et autre chose puisque on
a vu que même la plus grosse notoriété
qu'on a eu sur 50 ans Yvelines dans les
événements pensaient que c'était la
Ridder Cup c'était c'était
on apprend voilà mais tant mieux mais de
toute façon il est devenu en fait le le
premier centre médical
en cas d'urgence contre la pandémie donc
oui aujourd'hui il a demain si on a une
autre pandémie on a une réactivité
encore plus forte bien sûr en France
voilà donc ça sert aussi mais au vélo
etc ça va être très médiatisé pendant
je crois que le vélodrome est classé
dans un des sites qui va être le plus
médiatisé encore que également le VTT va
être original en plus le projet est beau
donc
regarde ça ils sont enchantés et d'abord
il voit que les élus enfin ce sont mis
d'accord sur un projet depuis 30 ans
c'est sûr alors l'autre projet aussi qui
va prendre Corse cette année c'est celui
du commissariat d'agglomération qui doit
avoir le jour dans la zone des quatre
arbres c'est un projet que vous portez
depuis une dizaine d'années pareil ce
qu'il y a du nouveau du concret sur ce
dossier la même chose dans lequel la
décentralisation laissons les
collectivités
s'occuper des des choses de proximité
comme ça ça fait 10 ans qu'on se bug
avec l'administration on je crois que
mon cellier c'est réglé on a mais oui on
finance on est compte un peu c'est au
collectivités de financer première
mission égalienne de l'État parce que il
y a plus d'argent on vous le dit pas
mais il y a plus d'argent regardez les
médecins tout le monde gueule etc mais
pourquoi parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens
de désormais les médecins mais il faut
le dire allez voir dans l'université on
a changé ils ont un échangé du tout ils
jouent pour on n'aura pas plus de
médecins parce qu'il y a plus l'argent
ça coûte cher de faire un médecin donc
il faut produire de la richesse il faut
augmenter la production de richesse
c'est que demain si je disais les
syndicalistes il disait mais vous voulez
qu'on vous demande votre salaire et bien
vous mettez au niveau allemand vous
aviez le même niveau de production de
richesse il y a quelques années vous
reprenez le même niveau de production
des chaises mais vous vous adaptez aussi
un peu avec les règles du jeu et si vous
avez le même niveau moi je vous augmente
vos salaires de 20%. donc dites-vous
bien une chose que tout ça on va régler
nos problèmes si on augmente simplement
si on passe de 67% d'actifs qui bossent
à 77 comme les Allemands mais je peux
vous dire il y a plus de problèmes de
retraite il y a plus de problèmes
d'équilibre du budget et là on retrouve
un système sain et c'est la solution
pour pour réformer le service public la
santé de l'éducation la police qui
manque cruellement de moyens donc en
tout cas ce projet de sécurité du futur
puisque même le ministère me dit bien
que c'est il y a beaucoup de
commissaires qui se construisent mais le
seul qui a le label commissaire du futur
c'est effectivement celui de 50 ans il
est très
avec toutes les technologies donc voilà
c'est vous connaissez la culture
numérique et la culture numérique de
Saint-Quentin est très forte et bien sûr
sert à ce projet bien sûr donc dès cette
année pour le début des travaux du coup
ou c'est pas encore fini
le budget est là bien sûr et non ça y
est essayé tout le monde est pas prêt
d'accord mais 10 ans
cher ami un français des projets s'il
faut 10 ans à chaque fois il va falloir
simplifier les lois et on l'a enfin on
l'a montré encore récemment on veut il
faut que les gens comprennent qu'on peut
pas la France ne peut pas garder une
culture administrative aussi
paralysante c'est pas possible on peut
pas freiner une initiative sportive ou
économique comme cela donc de toute
façon il faut changer ce pays il faut il
faut lui faire confiance aux
collectivités je pense il faut il faut
insuffler une culture entrepreneuriale
beaucoup plus forte il faut que le
processus des signaux il y a des chefs
d'entreprise et des administratifs on
veut pas comme ça abandonner tout le
système de décision politique française
uniquement à une classe et il faut
arrêter ça il faut des gens il faut les
doubles cultures il faut la double
culture très rapidement est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres projets alors tout début
d'année l'inauguration de terrain de nos
terrains de tennis aussi à Élancourt ça
fait partie des projets qui voient le
jour est-ce que il y en a un autre que
vous souhaitez mettre en avant alors
celui il faut tout se dire le terrain de
tennis ben de toute façon on était
obligé obsolète il faut le dire et puis
de toute façon le projet de commissariat
arrivant voilà il fallait bon donc il
fallait de toute façon le déplacer donc
en le déplaçant on le modernisait donc
effectivement il y a un très beau un
très bel ensemble de polythéisme
aujourd'hui et qui permet aussi de faire
arriver le fameux commissariat de 50 ans
de Nîmes qui va être un des
commissariats de France et on termine
cette entretien Jean-Michel fourgouse
avec l'interview express
[Musique]
alors le principe 5 questions des
réponses courtes on a posé les mêmes
questions à l'ensemble des mers qui sont
venus sur ce plateau au cours du mois de
janvier parfois quelques explications je
me demandais s'il y a une explication en
20 secondes maximum première question
Jean-Michel fourgault c'est ce qu'en
2023 vous augmenterez les impôts locaux
à Élancourt écoutez les impôts dans les
10 dernières années c'était 35%
d'augmentation au niveau national et
nous on était à 17 c'est-à-dire deux
fois moins maintenant je ne prendrai
aucune
aucun engagement devant mes électeurs ou
alors ils me disent que la guerre est
terminée il me disent que le nucléaire
on revient à 80% et non pas 40 avec qui
est quand même la meilleure garantie
qu'on est sur le sur l'impact des coûts
de l'énergie sur nos budgets voilà si
une garantissage leur garantie que
j'augmente pas mais le contexte
difficile voilà on fouette sérieux on
peut pas prendre moi vous savez je j'ai
baissé les impôts même 50 ans je me suis
quand même de 25% c'est assez rare quand
même je suis plutôt là-dessus mais je ne
prendrai pas je suis un garçon sérieux
je ne vais pas promettre des bêtises
comme ça en tout cas je ferai au minimum
vous savez l'impôt tu l'impos il y a
trop d'impôts en France on a le record
donc faut arrêter ça donc vous savez je
suis sur cette ligne là mais ne me
demandez pas un chiffre précis je ne
sais pas si 4 questions un peu plus
rapidement sur la circulation certaines
communes ont fait le choix des 30 km/h
de limitation est-ce que vous êtes pour
ou contre oui mais selon à mon avis
les quartiers selon l'endroit où c'est
moi je suis très
c'est les grandes lois générales
attention
mais tranquillement c'est raisonnable
dans certains quartiers bien entendu
parler sur le bio certaines communes ont
fait le choix du lieu dans leur cantine
est-ce que à votre avis il faut une
obligation du bio dans les cantines ou
une incitation peut-être on arrête avec
ça ou alors mes chers amis ont garanti
le pouvoir d'achat des Français qui est
stable pendant 20 ans le bio c'est 30%
plus cher d'accord faut faut le dire
alors quand on voit le pouvoir d'achat
des Français qui baisse va falloir aussi
et les moyens des collectivités qui
payent les cantines avec j'en ai
contribuable quand même voilà faut pas
prendre d'engagement je pense qu'il faut
faire confiance à son maire je pense que
les maires sont les élus les plus chéris
par les Français je pense qu'il y a des
raisons d'ailleurs ce qui sont de
proximité et donc voilà c'est des gens
sérieux donc gardons confiance mais je
prendrai pas l'engagement dessus même si
on fait du bio selon mais voilà on va
pas on va pas augmenter au-delà on
respecte la loi là-dessus on l'a vu dans
l'actualité malheureusement des maires
des élus victimes d'agression de menaces
est-ce que dans l'exercice de vos
fonctions vous êtes déjà senti menacés
oui on a on a des gestes d'incivilité de
certains jeunes m'ont le plus c'est bien
ça c'est sur Trab dès qu'on s'est c'est
quand même un territoire très
particulier
où il faut effectivement je crois qu'il
faut réexpliquer les valeurs de la
République les valeurs de respect tout
ça il y a tout un travail à faire mais
en dehors non pas Élancourt mais mais si
mes collègues me le disent enfin moi
j'ai eu j'étais trois fois agressé mais
à Paris mais paradoxalement il faut le
faire
et je crois qu'on était classé dans une
des villes les plus sûres dans les 10
villes les plus sûrs je crois dans une
étude qui parlait dans Le Parisien je
crois des Yvelines bon et que on
travaille et a priori si demain vous
avez le commissariat il permet voilà à
Élancourt pour 50 ans et demi je pense
que les élans encore toi vont à faire
des effets secondaires plutôt positifs
d'aider les gens de de leur faire gagner
du temps de leur faire gagner de la
qualité de la vie de veiller à leur
pouvoir d'achat selon le contexte bien
sûr
d'améliorer le modèle éducatif
d'améliorer la sécurité
de de les prix de fleurissement enfin on
a 54 je relisais on a 54 repris les
labels Élancourt oui l'équipe est
motivée ils se sentent bien ils sont
fiers et on le voit bien sentiment
d'appartenance des élans courtois et de
mes collaborateurs qui est bon et j'ai
pas de départ de mes collaborateurs je
veux dire que c'est c'est
président de 50 ans en Yvelines et très
bonne année 2023 dans votre ville et
votre agglomération merci beaucoup
[Musique]
et l'ensemble de ces interviews avec les
maires de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à
retrouver sur notre site Internet TV
78.com on ouvre à présent et une page
culture dans ce 7 8
[Musique]
avec dans un instant nos invités qui ne
m'ont rejoint autour de la table et on
va débuter avec cette disparition
survenue brutalement en fin de semaine
dernière marque Fafer directeur du
Théâtre de Poissy et décédé le 27
janvier à l'âge de 64 ans d'une
septicémie foudroyante et depuis des
hommages ont été rendus au créateur du
festival de musique de l'Estival
regardez ce reportage de Régine
ralechfer laisse derrière lui le
souvenir d'un homme passionné depuis
l'annonce de sa mort les hommages se
multiplient comme celui de karlive
ancien maire de la commune tout passe
tous ces faces tu aurais pu attendre
hier soir tu es parti sans nous dire au
revoir on rêvait de Louis Chedid toi et
moi ou encore Sandrine bernaude Santos
l'actuel maire le théâtre Molière perd
un directeur remarquable qui avait su
insuffler sa passion à toute une équipe
une minute de silence suivie d'une
minute d'applaudissement ont également
été respectées par le public du théâtre
dont il était directeur depuis 2015
sa passion pour le spectacle commence en
1978 avec une bande de copains
organise des concerts sur une péniche
amarrée à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine 10
ans plus tard il lance l'Estival un
festival de musique indépendant
plusieurs jeunes talons font alors la
première partie d'artistes de renom
comme Eddy Mitchell Jimmy Cliff ou
encore Johnny Cleg moi j'étais à la
création de ce festival donc
l'évolution allait bien entendu très
importante puisque on était plus sur
Saint-Germain à une époque puis on a
ouvert vers d'autres villes et là on
ouvre vers d'autres villes encore plus
sa compagne Maryline Boisselier et ses
fils Victor et Robin durant hommage à
travers une lettre Marc Pfeiffer homme
au mille vies né au Cameroun ardent
défenseur de la chanson francophone
toujours prêt à relever les défis les
plus fondateur et ancien président de la
Fédération des festival pas mal de
chansons francophones fait des chansons
directeur du Théâtre de Poissy depuis
2015 il savait faire rayonner l'art
vivant sous toutes ses formes car vivant
il l'était passionnément eternellement
Marc Pfeiffer s'est éteint à l'âge de 74
ans dans la nuit du jeudi 26 au vendredi
27 janvier
alors différents sujets dans la suite de
cette particululture on va parler dans
un instant de musique aussi de
littérature mais d'abord on parle de
théâtre dans le 7 8 avec les 40 ans
d'une compagnie emblématique du
territoire yvelinois c'est la troupe du
crâne et on en parle avec Christophe
Leray bonsoir vous êtes le président de
cette troupe du crâne un bon
anniversaire à vous alors l'anniversaire
officiel c'était même l'année dernière
puisque la troupe a été créée en 1982 on
va revenir sur cette histoire mais
l'anniversaire va se poursuivre avec
cette année 2023 et des notamment des
représentations dont on va parler qui
ont lieu des ce week-end à Maurepas déjà
40 ans pour une troupe de théâtre ça
représente quoi pour vous bien beaucoup
de rencontres beaucoup de comédiens et
beaucoup de spectacles surtout dans des
configurations très différentes et
vraiment de très belles aventures il y a
35 membres dans cette troupe du crâne 14
comédiens l'objectif c'est de monter une
ou plusieurs pièces de faire partager
ses créations tout au long de d'une
saison oui exactement il y a la volonté
de faire vivre les spectacles les
anciens de créer toujours aussi de
nouvelles productions et puis d'avoir un
pôle d'élèves donc on a des ateliers
justement pour les niveaux collégiens
lycéens donc il y a aussi cette idée de
la transmission qui est très importante
pour la créatrice parce que il y a un
personnage central dans dans une
personne centrale dans cette histoire on
le disait ça a été créé en 1982 la
fondatrice c'est Monique fondidon qui
est toujours aujourd'hui la méthode en
scène de cette compagnie qui a joué un
rôle important tout au long de
l'histoire le personnage qui est
fédérateur c'est elle qui a créé donc
cette association en 82 elle a donc eu
au par le passer une une carrière sur
Paris une formation au Conservatoire et
puis quand elle a emmagé dans les
Yvelines elle a eu le souhait de
justement de créer sa propre compagnie
et ça s'est fait dans des conditions
presque un pittoresque dans une grange
avec quelques petits moyens et puis au
fil des décennies on a eu des lieux des
subventions le soutien de la ville de
Coignières de Maurepas et puis et puis
après la résidence puisqu'on joue au
théâtre Alphonse Daudet où c'est notre
voilà notre théâtre de résidence et là
qu'on travaille deux trois fois par
semaine et puis après bien l'histoire a
pris beaucoup d'ampleur votre métier
vous vous êtes scénographe parce que
vous exercez comme profession vous donne
notamment à l'indifférente scènes de
compte celles du château de Breteuil
pour ne citerkel la troupe du crâne nous
y être entré à 13 ans qu'est-ce qui a
fait que vous êtes tourné vers le
théâtre à l'époque et qu'est-ce que ça
vous a apporté alors ça m'a apporté
énormément de choses donc oui je suis
rentrée à 13 ans j'en ai 35 donc ça fait
tes mises en scène par par Monique fondu
Lyon différentes dates alors celles que
je m'étais notée il y en a beaucoup en
mai 2018 c'est aussi la troupe qui
obtient sa première licence de spectacle
et qui peut honorer des engagements
professionnels c'est vrai que peu à peu
on est passé d'une aventure amateur à
une aventure quasiment professionnelle
exactement grâce à cette licence on a pu
honorer des engagements professionnels
on a eu l'opportunité de jouer au
château de Fontainebleau pendant 50
représentations le spectacle de la Belle
et la Bête gros partenariat un énorme
partenariat et du coup bien ça nous a ça
a été des tremplins et puis les
engagements sont arrivés aussi donc il
fallait avoir la structure
administrative pour donc on a fait
évoluer les choses alors pour fêter cet
anniversaire je disais donc 1982 2022
mais ça se poursuivre en 2023 il y a
notamment des photos qui sont exposées à
l'espace Albert Camus de Maurepas et je
le disais deux représentations au
programme ce week-end à l'occasion du
Festival Plein feu c'est toujours à
l'espace Albert Camus déjà samedi 4
février à 20h30 c'est un un fil à la
pâte qui est donc par votre troupe la
troupe du crâne est mise en scène de
signer de Monique fondidon
finalement fedo ça fait partie un peu de
vos classiques ça a été souvent souvent
on a joué pas mal de pièces du
vaudeville effectivement c'est très
difficile à jouer avec votre ville parce
que ça demande une énergie d'enfer c'est
un rythme effréné ça demande une grande
concentration une grande précision mais
surtout beaucoup de folie et dans le fil
à la pâte on ne Déroche pas à la règle
c'est 2h30 c'est un grand spectacle avec
un beaucoup de costumes des décors une
équipe une équipe de fou furieux et
c'est vraiment un spectacle où le rire
est à chaque situation donc on en a
beaucoup besoin et je crois que
c'est une belle manière d'honorer le les
40 ans de la troupe dans la joie et la
bonne humeur et le lendemain à 16h je
précise juste qu'il y aura une pièce de
Molière c'est Bourgeois Gentilhomme il y
a toutes les informations qui vont
s'afficher notamment aussi pour pour la
billetterie j'ai envie de vous poser
cette question qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter
à la troupe 40 ans supplée 40 ans de
plus continuons continuons cette belle
aventure et vivons les choses
intensément parce que rien ne remplacera
le spectacle vivant et je pense que les
personnes qui sont à mes côtés le
confirmeront aussi c'est un lien entre
le public et les artistes sur scène qui
est unique c'est une expérience à vivre
à tous les niveaux et je crois qu'il
faut l'encourager et vivre le théâtre et
vive la scène tout simplement merci
merci beaucoup Christophe Laurent d'être
passé en plateau pour en parler bon
anniversaire une nouvelle fois à la
troupe du crâne qui c'est 40 ans et bien
sûr des temps forts à venir à toutes les
informations via les liens les liens qui
s'affichent en bas de l'écran merci
beaucoup merci après le théâtre on passe
aux champs déjà peut-être une petite
réaction il parlait beaucoup de présence
scéniques c'est aussi très important
pour le champ Audrey Bohan exactement en
plus que coach scène c'est aussi ce que
je travaille avec les artistes et
sur lesquels on bosse beaucoup avec Ben
les candidats qu'on accompagne parce que
c'est un moment de partage on partage
des émotions
un moment d'évasion pour les gens c'est
un moment pour se retrouver pour donner
donc voilà alors je le disais en début
d'édition vous venez nous parler de
cette finale du tremplin des voix la
huitième saison de ce tremplin la fin
approche de cette 8e saison sera le
samedi 11 février pour cette finale à
19h à partir de 19h à la Maison de
l'Environnement de Magny-les-Hameaux et
vous avez été rejoint en face de vous
par deux candidats justement qui seront
sur scène le 11 février il y a Emma sur
la droite qui est habitant de Chevreuse
vous êtes candidate dans la catégorie
des interprètes 17 ans et moins bonsoir
et à côté de vous tous kata qui est elle
habitant de Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est
bien ça et vous êtes vous candidat dans
la catégorie interprète 18 ans et plus
on va déjà commencer par faire votre
connaissance Emma toutata comment ou
vous êtes arrivés dans dans le monde de
la musique comment vous êtes tombé
dedans et
quel est votre parcours aujourd'hui
alors d'abord moi j'ai commencé à
chanter quand j'étais toute petite et
mon rapport avec la musique il s'est
beaucoup agrandi quand j'arrive au lycée
j'ai monté un groupe avec mon frère et
des amis et là on a commencé à découvrir
un peu la scène et ça c'est encore plus
agrandi du coup avec la découverte du
tremplin des voies et je précise que
vous avez 16 ans en tout cas même
question comment vous êtes tombé dans la
musique et qu'elle a été votre parcours
depuis la musique c'est depuis que je
suis toute petite aussi du coup vu que
ma maman a chanté tout le temps et que
ça m'a donné envie de chanter également
j'ai commencé à prendre des cours plutôt
avec Audrey Bron justement que j'ai
rencontré en 2019
et c'est grâce à elle aujourd'hui si je
fais vraiment beaucoup de scènes je suis
beaucoup plus à l'esthétiquement et que
je suis fière de pouvoir faire la finale
du Tremplin aujourd'hui chose que
j'aurais pas pu faire sans elle du coup
je pense mais vous avez 32 ans donc vous
êtes deux candidates
ivinoises et je le disais c'est 22
finalistes au total avec trois
catégories qui vont monter sur scène le
11 février exactement donc en plus on a
les auteurs compositeurs interprètes qui
viennent avec leur titre original
on a des candidats qui viennent de toute
la France donc
et puis même de l'île de la Réunion
puisque on a aussi on intervient aussi
là-bas pour repérer des nouveaux talents
de différents âges aussi à des avancées
peut-être différentes dans leur projet
musical c'est ça c'est que on accompagne
chacun où il en est dans son parcours
donc que ce soit un artiste qui démarre
et un artiste qui a des titres des
compositions qui envoient de par exemple
enregistrer son EP qui a la recherche
d'un Norauto d'un entourage
professionnel de d'être repéré donc
voilà le tremplin des voix c'est un
dispositif d'accompagnement et on essaye
d'apporter les outils nécessaires au
développement de la carrière de
l'artiste donc la finale va mettre fin à
cette huitième saison derrière cet
événement rappelle l'association l'avant
en scène 250 candidatures au départ
qu'elles ont été les différentes étapes
pour arriver jusqu'à cette finale donc
250 candidatures avec une nouveauté
encore cette année on essaie de
améliorer encore d'année en année donc
on a organisé des des jambes des Open
Mike des karaoké où on est venu sur des
avec des partenaires existants sur des
événements comme ça pour repérer des
nouveaux talents
pour les inciter à s'inscrire du coup
et puis ensuite vient les étapes
habituelles donc audition
puis demi-finale qui existe depuis deux
ans et puis maintenant la finale
exactement donc ça fait à peu près 250
candidatures 140 auditionnés à peu près
60 demi finalistes et on est à 22
finalistes et pourquoi vous vous êtes
inscrits du coup inscrit toutes les deux
à ce tremplin Emma moi j'ai vu une
annonce avec ma mère sur Internet on
était un peu à la recherche de concours
et du coup on s'est inscrit parce que
enfin je me suis inscrite parce que ça
nous a beaucoup attiré
c'était vraiment par hasard que j'étais
tombée sur l'annonce du Tremplin en 2019
et la petite anecdote c'est que j'avais
fait l'audition et ça c'était pas très
bien passé et j'ai travaillé sur moi
même pour vraiment être un peu plus à la
scéniquement et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je peux enfin faire la
finale du coup ce que ça va mieux sur
scène
pour le théâtre elles vont être
accompagnées ouais jusqu'à cette finale
pour préparer justement cet événement
faut savoir que la voix enseigne en fait
on a un organisme de formation qui
accompagne on fait du coaching vocal du
coaching scène du coaching studio et du
coup notre objectif dans ce tremplin la
particularité c'est de les accompagner
avec nos coachs au fur et à mesure donc
pendant toutes les étapes ils ont été
chauffés on a parlé de la scène de la
présence de tenir le micro par exemple
de s'adresser au public et plus ils
avancent dans les étapes et plus les
coachings sont resserrés au début c'est
des grands groupes on fait des des
petits échauffements et tout ça puis là
ils arrivent en étape où c'est de
l'individuel quasiment et comment va se
dérouler la finale du coup
alors la finale bah du coup ça commence
à 19h avant ils ont de préparation donc
ce week-end ils sont en répétition déjà
avec les musiciens puisque c'est l'étape
où ils sont en live donc avec 8
musiciens des choristes
la semaine prochaine donc ils ont enfin
déjà ce weekend ils ont des coachings
individuels la semaine prochaine ils ont
des coachings collectifs de la
préparation répétition et travail sur
scène et puis après le samedi il y a la
représentation devant le public avec un
vote interactif du public du jury aussi
donc il y a deux prix Prix du Jury prix
du public donc le Prix du Jury c'est par
catégorie donc il y aura premier prix
deuxième prix de chaque catégorie et le
prix du public ce sera toute catégorie
confondues il y aura premier deuxième et
troisième prix je crois on sera en
configuration normale pour la première
fois depuis le covid mais il y a
toujours la possibilité de suivre à
distance aussi cette finale on sera en
direct bah du coup sur Youtube et tous
les autres réseaux sociaux de en scène
vous êtes dans quel état d'esprit là un
peu plus d'une semaine maintenant de
cette finale stressée mais on a hâte je
pense
le stress commence à monter mais on a
quand même hâte de le faire
et on le rappelle donc cette finale du
tremplin des voies ce sera le 11 février
prochain du côté de la Maison de
l'Environnement de Manille le hameau
soirée à partir de 19h une question
rapide pratique faut prendre son billet
avant pour pour pouvoir assister à la
finale idéalement faut prendre son
billet avant on espère arriver avant le
confinement en toute cette période où on
était complet donc voilà donc on
conseille au maximum de prendre des
places avant pour pas avoir de mauvaises
surprises et de se dire bah mince on
pensait pouvoir venir sur place et
prendre nos places voilà après
on peut quand même venir sur place si
c'est pas complet
merci à vous d'être venu en parler bon
courage également à vous pour cette
finale qui aura lieu le 11 février
prochain à Manille les hameau on parlait
tout à l'heure des 40 ans de la troupe
du crâne le centre artistique de Londres
à Vélizy-Villacoublay faites-lui cette
année c'est 20 ans pour l'occasion le
site à convier la compagnie à la
Carabosse pour illuminer les yeux du
public c'était samedi dernier torche
enflammée musique live était proposé
dans une ambiance chaleureuse on revient
sur cet événement avec Julien Leroy et
Régine ralech on n'a pas tous les jours
20 ans le centre artistique long de
Vélizy-Villacoublay fête son
anniversaire tout au long de l'année
2023 célébration d'une programmation
pluridisciplinaire orientée vers
l’écriture contemporaine théâtre danse
musique ou encore cirque sont proposés
dans la structure de 17000 mètres carrés
c'est ce que le spectacle vivant produit
aujourd'hui et souvent dans ces
propositions il y a des gens
extraordinaires le renouvelle les genres
et renouveler les gens c'est aussi
amener vers la surprise vers des
émotions nouvelles pour ces 20 ans
longues avec conviés la compagnie
Carabosse avec son installation de feu
sur le parvis une balade chaleureuse
dont le froid hivernal 500 torches
enflammés et fontaines incandescentes
étaient disposées autour du public ce
samedi 28 janvier le collectif
d'artistes parcourt le monde avec ses
installations depuis une trentaine
d'années moi depuis Gama j'adorais la
flamme et c'est quelque chose qui
rapproche qui rapproche les gens en fait
qui ont du feu on se sent bien et à tout
un truc de chaleur qui est quand même
hyper sympathique pour tout le monde
c'est le rapprochement des gens je crois
en fait qui nous plaignent dans ce qu'on
fait on avait un peu l'impression d'être
dans un autre monde quand on marchait
tout ça et c'est super beau surtout
l'advive
pour nous on habite pas très loin mais
voilà on découvre une nouvelle place et
un beau bâtiment et belle manifestation
prochain rendez-vous anniversaire pour
long de le 10 juin 2023 le chorégraphe
autrichien Willy Dorner organisera une
déambulation autour de sculptures
humaines dans les rues de
Vélizy-Villacoublay
[Musique]
de nouvelles personnes m'ont rejoint en
plateau beaucoup de turnover dans ce 7 8
Véronique Iturbide bonsoir Véronique
les insolites de Véronique pour voir les
informations qui fait pas rater dans les
départements des informations qui
sortent de l'ordinaire on va parler de
quoi dans un instant alors on va rester
avec lui on vient d'en parler parce
qu'il y aura une avant-première à l'UGC
Vélizy le mardi 7 février donc je vous
dirai quoi tout à l'heure après je vous
parle du festival des langues anciennes
qui a lieu à Versailles ou des langues
classiques tiens je me suis trompé
pardon merci voilà et pour finir
l'ouverture du café joyeux à part les
deux on en parle dans un instant il y a
aussi en face de vous Nicolas dandry de
la rédaction
journaliste c'est le passionné de rugby
que qui est avec nous avant tout ce
qu'on va parler de rugby quelques jours
du de l'ouverture de ce tournoi des 6
nations le 15 de France qui va défendre
son titre et ce Grand Chelem réalisé en
2022 avec cette génération talentueuse
qui est issue d'une formation au rugby
qui évolue de plus en plus on parle de
formation au rugby et je le disais avec
Xavier Brissard qui est aussi avec nous
rebons soir vous êtes originaire de
Magny-les-Hameaux habitants de
Magny-les-Hameaux et on va parler
notamment avec vous de ce livre qui
s'appelle l'art de la guerre du rugby
alors je parle un petit peu aussi de
votre parcours vous avez commencé à
Saint-Cyr l'école rugby Université Club
c'est ça RUC voilà j'avais le petit
sigle mais effectivement c'est bien ça
qui est devenu ensuite le Sky rugby vous
êtes ensuite aller au club de Massy en
catégorie des moins de 16 ans et
aujourd'hui vous exercez au sein de
l'école de rugby du Racing 92 des moins
de 14 ans et donc vous avez publié ce
livre mais déjà on va parler peut-être
un peu de formation avant de parler de
ce livre et parler de cette équipe de
France je disais qu'il va commencer son
tournoi des 6 nations toutou
prochainement dans les prochains jours
ce week-end elle reflète quoi cette
équipe selon vous est-ce que ça reflète
justement l'art de la formation
française selon vous cette équipe de
France talentueuse oui on a retrouvé en
a retrouvé certainement notre identité
qu'on avait perdu il y a quelques années
essayant de copier un petit peu ce qui
se faisait de mieux ailleurs on avait un
petit peu perdu notre notre rugby et
depuis quelques quelques mois années on
a retrouvé cette ce qu'on appelle le
French fly du jeu de mouvement du jeu
rapide et
c'est intéressant c'est un joueur qui
incarne peut-être se French fleurs c'est
Antoine Dupont avec sa technique
individuelle alors on est on est loin
des des joueurs de rugby avec un énorme
gabarit qui influe des gros impacts on a
connu aussi le grand public a connu
Sébastien Chabal là on est sur un profil
tout à fait différent oui oui après
Sébastien Dupont il fait pas 60 kg non
plus Antoine Sébastien
un peu moins de poils
donc Antoine pardon excuse-moi Antoine
Dupont c'est c'est un athlète c'est un
athlète c'est des sportifs de haut
niveau donc ils sont ils sont quand même
costauds et c'est un excellent défenseur
c'est un il pèse beaucoup donc il est
très puissant il est très technique et
très puissant mais Xavier quand on voit
dans votre livre justement que
aujourd'hui tout le monde peut jouer au
rugby peut-il ou gros gabarit finalement
quand on voit que aujourd'hui le
meilleur joueur français c'est Antoine
Dupont alors que il y a plus de 15 ans
c'était Sébastien Chabal avec et en plus
dans le jeu Sébastien Chabal il était
connu et fameux pour ses gros placages
et ses gros impacts aujourd'hui c'est
Antoine Dupont parce que il a ce jeu de
passer rapide il a plus la technique de
l'évitement on voit qu'il y a quand même
une évolution et qui reflète aussi ce
que vous dites dans le livre alors
effectivement après c'est ce qui est
intéressant au rugby c'est tous les
enfants à leur place dans un équipe de
rugby il faut des très grandes des tout
petit des qui vont vite dès qu'ils sont
agiles et qui sont puissants il faut
tout tout toute forme de taille de
gabarit et c'est super pour les gamins
parce qu'un gamin à l'école qui a un
petit peu gros dont on va se moquer un
petit peu ça va peut-être être plutôt la
star de l'école de l'équipe de rugby
donc donc ça valorise chaque individu ça
c'est bien après faut faire la
différence entre le rugby pro et le
rugby amateur
le rugby amateur ce sont tous des
athlètes de haut niveau on est dans du
sport à très haut niveau le rugby dont
moi je parle c'est du rugby de formation
d'éducation qui peut amener à devenir
sportif de haut niveau bien sûr mais où
la taille et le poids ont beaucoup moins
d'importance voilà vous parlez justement
d'une méthode d'éducation au rugby pour
les 5 saisons c'est le pourquoi comment
conséquence en quoi ça consiste cette
méthode et pourquoi en parler justement
dans ce pourquoi la mettre en avant
alors c'est valable pour tout pas que
pour le rugby mais à partir du moment où
on demande un enfant de faire quelque
chose s'il comprend pas pourquoi il va
le faire il va pas forcément bien le
faire il va pas forcément être impliqué
il va pas faire forcément avoir l'envie
et puis et puis le fait donc simplement
de comprendre pourquoi on fait les
choses nous permettre de les faire mieux
voilà c'est du bon sens en fait et alors
comment justement on inclut qu'à ces
enfants très jeunes et bien les
positions du placage parce que c'est
facile avoir enfin c'est une technique
individuelle assez poussée quand même le
rugby mais et qui en plus garantit la
sécurité du joueur comment on fait pour
justement et vous l'expliquer dans le
livre pour garantir cette sécurité et
cette technique individuelle assez plus
jeune il faut vraiment effectivement
donner aux enfants toute la
répertoire de gestes techniques pour
qu'ils puissent ne pas se mettre en
danger travailler en toute sécurité et
c'est peut-être des couper certains
exercices comme on le faisait pas avant
leur apprendre à se baisser très bas il
suffit peut-être de partir d'une roulade
avant au moment où il se live ils sont
déjà très bas c'est des instant T sur
des exercices qu'on peut forcément de
rapport direct de l'extérieur avec le
rugby qui vont amener qui peuvent amener
ce genre de comportement la matrice de
rugby
les entraînements par semaine et puis
des tournois le dimanche
c'est ça
alors ça existe aussi en loisirs vous
pouvez commencer même en adultes en
rugby loisirs c'est plus compliqué pour
les filles en rugby loisir que le Touch
ah bon mais c'est ce qu'on va voir voilà
il faut démocratique une dernière
question peut-être Nicolas une dernière
question sur vous dites finalement ce
qu'il faut retenir de ce livre c'est que
le rugby c'est l'école de la vie et que
finalement on peut retranscrire tout ce
que vous dites dans le dans le livre à
la vie en général oui oui c'est vrai que
si
on se comportait dans la vie comme sur
un terrain de rugby la société se
porterait beaucoup mieux parce que parce
que sur un terrain de rugby les joueurs
qui sont à côté de nous ils peuvent ils
peuvent pas nous mentir ils peuvent pas
se cacher ils sont obligés d'être là au
soutien ou s'ils sont pas là ça se voit
tout de suite quoi donc on peut pas se
mentir sur un terrain de rugby du coup
ça crée ça crée de la confiance ça crée
de la
voilà le sport est un donne des le goût
de l'effort le donc mélanger le sport le
rugby la vie ça fait c'est enfin c'est
la même chose et pour en savoir plus
l'art de la guerre du rugby donc aux
éditions je disais des trois colonnes et
c'est écrit par vous Xavier Brissard
merci d'être venu en parler en plateau
merci à vous et on passe tout de suite
aux insolites de Véronique
avec désormais même un petit jingle pour
pour vous Véronique puisque vous nous
présenter chaque semaine vos insolites
c'est le mardi sur TV 78 des
informations qui sortent de l'ordinaire
et qui méritent toute notre attention
alors décidément les stars du cinéma
aiment venir dans les ibis parce que
vous nous parlez la semaine dernière
d'une avant-première la venue
d'Alexandre à Lamy cette semaine c'est
Philippe Lachaud ça sa bande à Fifi qui
vient présenter son son prochain film
voilà alors ils seront donc avisé à
l'UGC le mardi 7 février 20h45 la séance
avec une rencontre il rencontreront le
public après la projection la bande à
Fifi vous la connaissez ils sont
originaires des Yvelines il y a
notamment le film baby-sitting
baby-sitter
Paris à tout prix même visiting 2 et là
justement on a alibi.com 2 donc la bande
sera là Philippe la chaux il est Audi
Fontan taré Boudali Julien Rutti voilà
et c'est un film évidemment plein de
gags réjouissants jubilatoire il y aura
dans la
Gérard Jugnot Nathalie Baye Arielle
Dombasle et Didier Bourdon
de cortiqués quelques petits secrets
qu'ils auront ben on va essayer bien sûr
ouais ça donne envie dans un style
différent on peut le dire en 5e édition
du festival des langues classiques qui
se déroulent vendredi et samedi à
Versailles alors dis comme ça ça peut
faire un peu peur moi je veux dire un
assez mauvais souvenirs de mes cours de
latin personnellement au collège mais
donnez-nous envie c'est quoi ce festival
c'est très varié il y a plein de choses
il y a des rencontres des ateliers des
films des conférences ce sont donc des
langues anciennes oh mais vraiment j'ai
l'impression
quand même 5e édition chinois latin grec
vous aurez donc trois lieux le tel de
ville le l'Université Ouverte et le
l'UGC Roxane vous avez un programme très
chargé regarder sur le site de la mairie
vous avez par exemple Denis podalides
l'acteur de l'accueil Mehdi française
Versailles a d'ailleurs qui vient faire
une lecture sur les animaux fantastiques
de la littérature grecque vous avez
aussi
je vous donne quelques exemples mais il
y a plein de choses les bestiaires de
l'antiquité une conférence avec Michel
pastoraux Michel pastoraux c'est un
historien qui est spécialiste des
couleurs des symboles et des animaux car
ce que je n'ai pas dit décidément c'est
que le thème cette année c'était des
animaux et des hommes voilà et pour un
autre exemple pour terminer un atelier
origami avec 12 animaux de la mythologie
chinoise le samedi 4 je vous ai inscrit
Grégory l'inscription est faite ça
s'annonce passionnant
avec vos enfants ados franchement c'est
pas que sérieux et savon c'est aussi
ludique et ça va peut-être déclencher
des des vocations de délinistes de la
tennis
avec l'ouverture d'un café joyeux au
centre commercial Parly 2 au
généraux-court c'est quoi un café joyeux
ce qu'on peut appeler déjà alors un café
joyeuse c'est un concept en fait ce sont
des cafés dans lesquels vous trouvez 80%
des employés qui sont soit porteurs de
d'un syndrome autistique soit porteur de
trisomie 21 donc ça ça fait partie du
l'essentiel du personnel qui sont
encadrés par des managers qui sont donc
formés à ce genre de personnes un peu
atypiques et donc l'idée c'est de créer
du du lien de les inclure dans la
société de leur donner un travail un
salaire de l'autonomie de la confiance
en soi et donc ça s'appelle le café
joyeux il y en a plusieurs en France il
y en a un Lisbonne à Bruxelles c'est une
dizaine de France et donc celui-ci vient
d'ouvrir à parler dedans le centre
commercial porte Saint Michel plus
précisément donc vous pouvez y aller
évidemment prendre un café vous pouvez y
aller déjeuner les cuisiner et faites
sur plat des produits frais de saison
les menus changent toutes les semaines
vous avez aussi un menu végétarien et
quoi dire d'autre et bien et bien une
petite info sur ce sujet parce que c'est
le premier dans le monde et c'est le
premier journal il faut savoir que
un souvenir c'est que avant le covid ce
projet était déjà sur la table parce que
ils envisagé d'ouvrir justement un café
joyeux à Versailles et donc bon il est
ouvert aujourd'hui à Parly 2 mais c'est
un projet qui date d'avoir le covid-19
avant 2020 bientôt à Versailles non le
projet donc je pense que voilà c'est
celui-là mais donc le la réflexion était
déjà en cours déjà avant le comido
est-ce que je trouve juste intéressant à
suivre c'est que franchement le centre
commercial Paris 2 c'est un peu le temps
de la consommation du paraître et là au
cœur de cet endroit il va y avoir mais
voilà du cœur justement de l'humain de
la chaleur humaine et et
un lieu qui a vraiment du sens
humainement parlant une initiative merci
Véronique on se retrouve bien sûr mardi
prochain
informations vous avez parlé en plus de
nourriture sur la fin ça nous a donné
faim c'est d'ailleurs bientôt l'heure de
passer à table
[Musique]
avec comme check mardi notre astuce du
chef les conseils de nos cuisiniers à
Yves Linois pour briller en cuisine
est-ce que vous êtes des amateurs de
foie gras autour de la table je sais que
oui le Sud-Ouest forcément
alors cette semaine c'est le chef maudit
Sakho du restaurant un restaurant
Versailles et si on peut me souffler le
nom dans l'oreillette je l'ai perdu les
quatre saisons merci à Mélanie poquet
qui est dans mon oreillette il nous
livre ce soir sa recette de l'escalope
de foie gras regardez
[Musique]
alors bienvenue au restaurant Les Quatre
Saisons je m'appelle monsieur Saco
maudit sur le chef de cuisine et
causérant des restaurants alors
aujourd'hui on va essayer de vous en
parler de des poils de foie gras avec et
pomme organismes et un petit bouillon de
taille
[Musique]
alors je vais vous présenter mon entrée
escalope des foie gras poêlé et Smith
mon petit astuce c'est les pommes grises
qui viennent apporter et en tout type
d'acidité assez foie gras pour les
réveiller un peu
[Musique]
merci à modisco vous me disiez Xavier
c'est comme ça que vous le préférez le
foie gras bon bah on va tenter la
recette
je suis pas trop fan mais moi le comme
ça le foie comme ça c'est parfait et ça
vous a donné envie bien sûr j'adore ça
sur toutes ces formes merci à vous trois
d'être venu en plateau merci encore une
fois à maudit Sako et c'est la fin de ce
7 8 merci de votre fidélité et demain la
présentation vous retrouverez Mathilde
Franco pour une nouvelle édition belle
soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]